it's still early days where devs are
already thinking about next-gen consoles
I'm Dave and welcome to a futuristic
gamespot news update criterion's former
tech director Paul Ross is currently
working with three fields entertainment
on its upcoming game dangerous golf
although released on ps4 and xbox one
this may that isn't stopping him from
think about the PS five and xbox two in
an interview with edge Ross talks about
how he would think about the next
generations of consoles when the team
started work on dangerous goals what
does a PlayStation five-game look like
what does an xbox two game look like
with ps4 we've seen some fidelity put
into world for ps5 is going to be about
dynamic worlds far more interactive
worlds that are more believable in the
way they behave ross also noted that
physics engines haven't really changed
since he works on the dreamcast game
trick style they're all about rigid
bodies solid objects this is a real
paradigm shift because it's about
simulating physics at a molecular level
it's been a really hard problem to solve
for quite a while dangerous golf is a
physics-based game that has players
destroying environments like gas
stations medieval castles and bathrooms
by playing golf indoors the game
releases this may on playstation 4 xbox
one and pc so what are you expecting for
the next generation of home consoles let
us know in the comments section below or
find me on Twitter at a regular Dave and
for your gaming news stay tuned to
gamespot com
you